[Music]
if you're anything like us then you must
be anxiously awaiting for new
information about descendants 3 while we
eagerly analyze any possible teasers or
trailers there's also a lot to learn
about the cast will tell you some things
you probably didn't know about antic at
cart before you get to see her
portraying dizzy in the new film but
first take a moment to hit the subscribe
button for more from the things okay
let's get started
youngest joining the cast of a sequel
can feel a lot like being the new kid at
school it's especially tough when you're
the youngest person on set in the first
descendants movie the youngest cast
member was Brenna D amico who plays the
fairy godmothers daughter Jane but
during descendants two there was a new
thirteen-year-old on the set named Anna
Cathcart who played the role of dizzy
it's impressive enough that this kid has
a descendents movie on a resume at age
13 but now Anna is adding another
descendants film at age 15 the favorite
being the youngest on set did not stop
Anna Cathcart from being an immediate
hit in descendants to Sofia Carson plays
Evie the daughter of the Evil Queen and
when she was asked who her favorite
character was in the franchise she
admitted that when it comes to the
sentence - she has a soft spot for Jers
Ella's daughter oh hey what a
coincidence
that happens to be dizzy played by Anna
Cathcart considering the fact that Evie
is a major character in both descendants
and descendants - we definitely consider
this high praise now when it comes to
director Kenny Ortega well Anna Cathcart
isn't exactly in his top 3 he says his
favorite characters are umma Harry and
Gil - all the boys I've loved before if
you loved seeing Anna Cathcart on screen
there are many more opportunities to see
her in action
she'll be starring in to all the boys
I've loved before based on the 2014
novel written by Jenny Han in the book
Laura Jean song Cobie writes love
letters to all her former crushes and
then one day they kind of end up getting
sent in the mail Anna will be playing
Laura's younger sister Catherine kitty
song Cobie
make sure your Netflix subscription is
up to date because that's where this
movie is getting released on August 17th
2018
odd squad before landing the role of
Disney and descendants to Anna Cathcart
was known for another notable role she
played the role of agent Olympia in the
TPO kids and PBS Kids comedy series odd
squad
it's an educational television series
where children use reasoning and
mathematical skills to investigate
strange occurrences and it's not just
your typical kids show this show has
aired all over the world impressed you
should be Anna reprise her role in the
2016 film adaptation of the series odd
squad
the movie since she's used to strange
and unexplained happenings on set we
that she had no problem transitioning to
descendants to fans if you're a fan of
Anna Cathcart you are not alone she may
be young but she's used to being the
center of attention from the time she
started playing the fun-loving agent
Olympia on odd squad she has built quite
a fan base with her adoring public
according to Anna she's constantly
approached by kids eager to score some
face time with their television hero
while some celebrities consider
interacting with their fans to be a
chore Anna says she's always happy to
share a smile a kind word or a photo
with one of her fans but if you think
about it it can't be easy to turn down
adorable kids even if she wanted to
dream come true perhaps another reason
that Anna Katkar is so generous with her
time and attention is because she knows
what it's like to be a huge fan just
like most of us and a watched and fell
in love with descendants auditioning for
the sequel was much more than just
another acting gig for her it was a
chance to be part of a series that she
was passionate about during her audition
she sang a meghan trainor song which was
apparently enough to impress the casting
directors getting to be a part of the
descendents franchise has been a dream
come true for Anna
Drizella we all know that Anna Cathcart
plays the sweet likable Drizzy term a
ninda sentence to her character is the
daughter of drizzly Tremaine one of
Cinderella's wicked stepsisters this
makes her the niece
Anastacia to remain and the
granddaughter of the wicked lady
tremaine and here's something for the
die-hard Anna Cathcart fans you know the
show on ABC once upon a time well the
episode entitled one little tear
features
Drizella as a young girl the person
chosen to portray young Drizella was
none other than Anna Cathcart is pretty
interesting that Anna ended up playing
the mother of her descendants to
character in a totally different
franchise Awards
getting to act in one of your favorite
franchises is reward enough and Anna
Cathcart has been nominated for many
other awards
thanks to her work on odd squad she's
been nominated for the best young
ensemble in a TV series by the Joey
Awards she's also been nominated for
best performance children or youth by
the Canadian Screen Awards in 2018 these
nominations alone are impressive and we
have no doubt they'll be plenty other
awards coming her way
castmates we know that a niqab carte
joined the cast for descendants too but
we want to know the other new members
the existing characters of descendants
had plenty of new faces to learn for
descendants - and dizzy was just the
start
who would forget Hoover super villain
uma who almost stole King been away from
mal the daughter of Ursula was played by
China and MacLaine and the one who told
us to get ready for the third film in
the series then there's Harry the son of
Captain Hook played by Thomas Dougherty
and Gaston son Gil played by Dylan play
fair even though she wasn't one of the
original cast members Anna maintains
that being on set felt like being a part
of one big happy family new family after
finding her place with her descendants
family things are about to shake up on
set for in a cat cart
she'll be back for descendants 3 along
with some brand-new characters
Hercules is one of the most underrated
Disney films of all time but the evil
character Hades is one of the best
lucky for us he'll be making an
appearance in two Senate's three played
by Cheyenne Jackson will also meet dr.
facili a from Princess and the Frog he's
played by Jamal Sims Kristen Convery and
Luke Rossler joins the cast as squeaky
and squirmy respectively this
of Peter Pan's mr. Smee we are insanely
excited to meet these and more new
characters when the film is released
rejection we the fans only see the good
parts of being an actor but there are
some serious drawbacks that we don't see
to get her role on odd squad and a
cathcart had to go through three
grueling rounds of the audition process
although she does credit her role of
agent Olympia for opening doors for her
the process still isn't easy not by a
long shot she explained that an actor
could go through over a hundred
auditions and still be rejected by every
single one she understands rejection is
just part of show business she just
isn't right for every role so Anna does
her best to take things in stride and
avoid taking it personally when she
isn't cast for a part in school being a
teen star can seem glamorous but they
have to do mundane things just like the
rest of us not only that but these
seemingly mundane tasks are sometimes
harder as a result of their job yes Anna
Cathcart and her co-stars on odd squad
still have to go to school because of
their shooting schedule traditional
school simply doesn't work while the
show is in production instead they take
classes in segments of two hours in
between scenes but there are the
occasional days where there's a lot that
needs to be filmed in that case school
work can be moved until later this can
add up to an extremely busy and long day
for Anna and her fellow actors skyhigh
okay Anna Cathcart doesn't get to escape
her school just because she's famous but
she does get some major perks not only
does she get to hang out with some
fabulous co-stars like Doug Cameron
Sophia Carson and Sarah Jeffery but
sometimes she gets to do it in the air
while filming descendants - and I got to
ride in a plane piloted by thee Jedediah
Goodacre who of course as you all know
plays Chad charming
apparently the cast enjoyed the outing
so much that they got to do it again
when filming descendants three except
this one wasn't piloted by Chad charming
but no matter the cast still got to
enjoy a scenic tour over vain
Canada it's going down since we've been
so distracted by descendants three it's
easy to forget how high we were for
descendants to back when we were
desperate for any bit of information
about the movie Disney Channel was kind
enough to provide us with a
behind-the-scenes special to obsess over
their release descendants - it's going
down which as we mentioned was a
behind-the-scenes peek at the making of
descendants - oh and the host yeah you
guessed it in a Cathcart if you haven't
already seen it it's a great watch it
has exclusive footage of director Kenny
Ortega on set and interviews with the
cast Instagram like tons of other
teenage girls and a cap dart has her
very own Instagram but unlike other
teens hers occasionally features some
behind the scenes looks so following her
is a must in addition to photos of her
cast mates Anna also gives us a glimpse
into her life she also enjoys posting
pictures of polaroid photos on her
Instagram so meta right now just over
two hundred thousand followers get to
admire her selfie game and see photos of
the cast and crew of The Descendants
franchise moving one of the most
interesting parts of The Descendants
franchise is getting to see the children
of some of our favorite villains
actually grow up while some of the
characters desire to be good others
struggle like now and some are very
happy with being the villains they are
like uma Anna's character dizzy grew up
with Sophia Carson's character Edie and
the two of them were close but Evie
ended up going to our don prep while
dizzy was left behind to toil at her
grandmother's hair salon but don't lose
hope
it looks like Anna is gonna have to get
used to acting on some new sets at the
end of the sentence - we learned that
dizzy finally gets her chance to go to
art on prep dizzy doll there are tons of
exciting things about being on
television and in movies you get to go
to fancy award shows hang out with
famous actors and maybe if you're lucky
star in your favorite franchise and with
all the famous actors out there
not all of them get to have their very
own doll yeah you heard me
Anna Cathcart has her very own doll
created by Disney for descendants to
fans it must be so surreal not to
mention creepy to come face to face with
the doll that looks exactly like you but
that's reality for a niqab cart what if
they come out with an updated version of
the doll based on what happens in the
senate's 3 dino dan odd squad isn't the
only television show that Anna Cathcart
has been a part of she's also been in
episodes of the Canadian television
series dino dan the series premiered on
TV o kids in Canada and shortly after on
Nick jr. in the United States it seems
like Anna is the perfect fit for
educational shows since Dino Dan teaches
kids about general science and of course
dinosaurs this show you ttle eise's both
live-action and CGI and follows
paleontologist wannabe Dan Henderson and
friends as they get up close and
personal with Dinosaurs Anna played a
character named Robin in the episodes
dinos of a feather and all in the Dino
family the new youngest as we mentioned
before then 13 year old Anna Cathcart
was the youngest cast member of
descendants to well she's gonna have to
give up the title of youngest when she
appears in descendants 3 there will be
at least one new 13 year old that we
know of and her name is Jada marine one
of the new characters in the third movie
is dr. facili a from the princess and
the frog played by Jamal Sims will also
meet his daughter Celia played by Jada
considering how the former youngest cast
member gets along with everyone now
we're sure Anna won't mind showing Jada
around the set dove Cameron so we
discussed that when she auditioned for
the role of dizzy descendants was
already in a cap guards favorite movie
not only was she a huge fan of the
franchise but there was one actress in
particular who earned her admiration
apparently Anna has always been a huge
fan of dove Cameron who plays mal in the
series the two seemed to have gotten
pretty close behind the scenes and dove
even compliments and as interview skills
during descendants two it's going down
it looks like despite the aged if
dov has taken young ana under her wing
nothing against ana but we are totes
jealous so we are dying to know what
characters you're most excited to see in
descendants three are you looking
forward to seeing an old favorite
or a brand new character let us know in
the comment section then hit the
subscribe button for more videos from
the things thanks for watching see you
next time
[Music]